hey what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of visual effects artist
react I'm going to kick things off with
a very special piece it's going to be
the gate oh what the that looks real
that looks real okay good
we're also gonna be taking a look at
real steel which some of you might
remember as the big robot fighting movie
but it also happens to be one of the
first virtual production movies ever
made oh also you may have seen this
trailer for a game called unrecord
God this looks so good mind-blowing ah
it's quite possibly the coolest most
photorealistic looking game ever created
no that game's just that's that's fake
that's just footage it's totally real
footage it's we're here to debunk the
fact that that's not actually a game
well you'll have to wait to find out
[Music]
they have opened
all right have you guys heard of the
gate nope I mean like I have a gate so
this is an amazing suggestion this came
about 1987 and you'll immediately see
familiarities with a popular TV show
that's out these days okay
oh this is stranger things stranger
things stranger things do they even use
the same font they do even use the same
phone same color it's all it looked like
it was almost the same font so the gate
is about this boy's tree house and it's
tree in the backyard and they cut it
down and the hole in the ground that it
opens up is a gate to another world a
gate to hell spoilers sorry foreign
[Music]
oh no his parents turned into demons
every kid's nightmare
oh oh
dude milky eyes Okay so hold on was this
a movie for children
because instantly I'm already like wow
this is pretty intense for a children's
this is a solid like give you nightmares
this is this is definitely like weirder
than stranger things oh no this is like
stranger things for babies compared to
this this is stranger things if it
actually came out in the 80s yeah yeah
oh oh
nothing marshmallows and black beans
that looks real that looks real good
there's collimation some of this is
claymation some of this is like a person
in a suit miniaturized the Shadows
wow holy hell
you better shut up you guys oh what the
wait dude wait a minute wait a minute
wait hold up hold up wait hold up hold
on pay attention watch yourself
you can pause this don't pause it don't
pause it
oh no
that's right out of Kevin Perry's
Playbook or the other way around I mean
yeah dude falling down to turn into a
banana so
okay so how did they do it no computers
are you saying this was all captured in
camera is there compositing happening at
least obviously there's that question I
didn't tell you you figure it out so
that that looks like it's a composited
Darby o'gilly situation
that's crazy what wait what no green
screens there's no mats at all this is
all 100 in camera this is insane it's
like the perspective thing I don't know
what's going on with their feet there
but it looks like that could be a large
set that's on the floor I think it's a
large set notice how they are
specifically having the actors perfectly
up against the wall and not really
moving their feet are static throughout
the course of this shot and I think I
see what you were talking about there's
like this little line that goes down and
around from the molding of the wall
around their toes to the bed yeah it
looks like wood panel floor has a little
bit more of a sheen on it I think you're
right it's a little bit more glossy I
think they recreated the look of this
room by scaling everything up probably
like five to six or seven times they
built a real Mega like two-story sized
chest of drawers all of the floor panels
are having to be like extra for large
panels this shot right afterwards when
you see them just in close up I think is
the best tell of that so this proves
that there's actually a full-size set
like a big set yeah those are people
wait that means they had to make a
full-size checkbook do you see that
checkbook on the ground that's where
those jumbo checks come from
[Laughter]
it's great though wait unless they're
doing this all in camera in which case
they are suspended up above it look at
that and
what
wait there's two chest of drawers it's
Darby o'gilly it's a Dario Gilly
situation Sam it's a rare Darby I can
see it now yeah there's two different
chests of drawers yeah isn't that crazy
so they actually had the kids suspended
12 feet off the floor standing in the
little corner of that spot that's close
to the camera and then everybody else is
far in the distance wow and then that
just means that the camera alignment has
to be like so methodically planned
because everything is being a
perspective match from that what I think
is a pain in the ass is there's that
splash of light on the door and the wall
and to have the same exposure levels on
the actual full size set behind them
like getting that to match with the
gradients and everything it's cool how
they just hung the foreground jacket off
the door and then let that actually
bleed into the other scene that's
actually a practically specifically
placed sweater or jacket hanging from
the door that actually does a good job
of covering up some of that line and
also the zombie at the beginning that
falls is a dummy because they have to do
it from like 12 feet up so you just have
them go and you just send them off the
platform and down to the stage below and
they just you use that you can't even
consider this dummy dude and honestly
that's what sells the scale more than
anything else you see a full-sized human
basically rests on the floor and you're
like okay I get it that's a floor and
that's the scale compared to this person
and then the little guys come out here
like oh they are actually tiny yeah it's
a great way to sell the effect so how do
you think they did this pan down from
the kid to his foot because that's a
crazy shot how did I do that that's an
impossible shot wow is that just a big
leg Yeah It's gotta be it's a Darby
o'gilly situation that's what I mean it
is it is it is it is that's a real
foreground leg and then the one in the
background
the big big one yeah because the jeans
are slightly different yes oh Gilly dang
Darby MF and Gilly and they're also
filming it in fast motion so the kid is
now barely moving because yeah these
guys are moving at normal speed and they
speed are all sort of sensing because on
the pan down you sense that it's under
cranked already so that means the top
and the bottom of that shot are
connected this one here it is
Darby oh yeah yeah okay yeah oh my God I
totally see it yeah you see it too wow
Darby oh Gilly that I know what to look
for there's that little line around the
stones yeah they did such a good job
matching the detail on the foreground
tiles the tiles that are literally feet
across compared to inches across but
like they still feel like they're the
same texture but added plants especially
watching it the first time this is on
the film you're in the theater you can't
rewind it yeah the shadow disappears
there but the date yeah oh they did a
fake Shadow on her toe they did
specifically timed up a fake Shadow
across her foot that moves when the guy
jumps back I was I was literally about
to say they even had the fourth out to
paint that darker and then the shadow
disappeared and it was like nope that
wasn't paint that's real Shadow covering
the light this blows my mind guys you
brought this one up first now everything
else is just going to be disappointed no
it's not all right here check out my
clips
God this looks so good mind-blowing
uh I yeah this was very confusing when I
first saw it and I'm pretty sure the
entire internet was also very confused
because it looks like real GoPro footage
it looks it looks like body cam footage
it looks like it's airsofting it looks
like everything you've ever seen from
this perspective it looks like it to the
point that people were like this is just
real footage this isn't gameplay footage
stop lying to us shots fired shots fired
yeah there's a lot of people that accuse
this guy of just uploading fake footage
which is absolutely ridiculous it's like
the best compliment you could possibly
get as like a video game level creator
so there you go see
just playing the map this is like the
actual definite proof that it was
definitely an unreal I think the auto
exposure Plug-In or whatever is working
there is doing so much of the heavy
lifting it's doing a ton of it the
sensation we're getting when we're
watching this that makes us go oh this
looks kind of real it's actually this
spectrum of really classic visual
effects tricks that we've talked about a
ton of times oh wait tell me more okay
so let's talk about that first one the
auto exposure shift yeah okay that's
like the first example that everyone
sees here it's the exposure on the trees
it's like they clip out they get white
they shrink they disappear into the like
bright overcast sky this is like
post-processing that we're talking about
here and there's other post-processing
stuff that's happening here that's a
little subtle too such as Barrel fisheye
Distortion he has a post-processing
Shader that's able to give us that nice
fisheye GoPro feeling clearly this
person has studied a lot of like GoPro 2
footage
plus that like shaking vignette yeah and
that little blue chromatic aberration on
the edge of the vignette that changes
depending on the exposure behind it like
it's really nice yeah the other thing
that really kind of sold this for me to
begin with was the Fidelity of the
animation of the hands it looked very
realistic yeah animation obviously is
like the huge cell with this if you're
seeing wobble with every footstep
basically that's a big part that's
selling it for me you're seeing micro
Jitter yeah ever since the day is the 5D
Mark II when everybody started shooting
on little plastic cameras everybody
started getting micro Jitters just
little tiny shakes you can only get when
your camera weighs two pounds you see it
here they're just little boop boop that
happens you know these steps and things
just shake just a little bit well that's
the thing if you have a GoPro mounted on
your chest or it's on a helmet or on
your face or whatever it's gonna wiggle
each step you take is gonna just take
those little joints your camera's
connected to and just wiggle them and
the camera is very very slightly and
it's and it's yeah it's enough it's like
a tiny vibration the last thing just to
mention here is a big part of all so
once again why does this look so
stupidly good well they're using tons of
photo scanned elements right a lot of
stuff that is on the unreal Marketplace
okay yeah it's like you have mega scans
you have all these other packs that are
coming out very very nice high quality
photo scan exactly this is just a real
environment that's been photo scanned
and then using some extra lighting you
know a couple little post-processing
tricks you don't use Photo scans and
games normally no it's because they're
too heavy and so this is like this is
too many polygons
yeah
is this the end of video this is kind of
the end of video game Graphics in the
sense that like when Unreal Engine 5
came out everyone was amp there's Loom
and there's nanite all these things you
get photo more photorealistic Lighting
on a fly and also you can do super
multi-million poly like objects in your
scene it's like this is what you this is
what we get now we get insanely detailed
like natural looking environments now
that can have tons of textures tons of
polygons tons of everything and now you
can only fit three games on your one
terabyte SSD yes all right guys we are
one subscriber away from having six
million 114 864 subscribers so please
help us put us over the line and
consider subscribing he's not lying
[Music]
yeah
exactly looking at it looks the most
requested it's been requested for a long
time yeah
[Applause]
it's the live action welcome robots I
think the first surprise I I had about
this movie was my assumption that all of
the robots were CG whereas in reality a
large chunk of the movie the robots are
practical and real really they were made
by a company called Legacy effects you
know they're responsible for a lot of
really cool practical things in movies
from like baby Yoda to like the suits
from Pacific Rim to a whole bunch of
other things they made a bunch it aids
the filmmaking so much for a number of
reasons one you can just get away with
not doing the effects is like the
obvious one if you have an actor
interacting with the robot in that
robot's gonna be CG oh boy you're in for
a challenging time so I want a shot over
the shoulder of the robot or like close
up on something while they're doing work
it's like you know what you want
something there for those shots you're
gonna sit there and render out those
shots it's obviously not enough to do
any real fighting but it's enough that
if the robot's like sitting there in
like Diagnostics mode and they're
welding something new on his arm he can
be like
to get all of the little close-up pickup
shots that you'd want to get but
secondly it gives you the world's best
reference for lighting and color and
what these robots would look like in any
sort of lighting condition half the
reason why they look so good in the end
is because they're able to match it to
something that's real we've got more
scenes in this episode but before we get
to them I just want to imagine for a
second wouldn't it be cool to have the
robots just like the ones in Real Steel
for your own personal machine because we
are giving away a 10 000 Puget PC we
wanted to offer that courtesy of Puget
now all you got to do is go out and get
one of these media offline shirts these
are limited edition in celebration of 13
years of Blood Sweat and media offline
here at Corridor now just like in Real
Steel we also name all of our machines
here this one's called Spider-Man this
one's called Poison Ivy we chose Marvel
names but you can choose to name it
whatever you want and and just like in
the movie you'll be controlling some
incredible power with these incredible
machines all you have to do is go to
quarter Digital Dot store and pick one
of these up before Sunday May 28th and
guess what one of those people is going
to win a Puget PC so step aside Real
Steel because we've got virtual robots
that are coming for you
what I didn't realize about this movie
was that it was actually a
groundbreaking virtual production film
oh really yeah the only other film that
had done any sort of virtual production
before this was Avatar how did you
Define virtual Productions so these days
virtual production kind of gets confused
with the sort of like volume stagecraft
stuff that you see for like Mandalorian
and all that stuff these days but
virtual production is just the act of
combining the real physical camera with
a digital twin camera all filming at the
same time and so what that allowed for
this movie is that they were able to do
all of the choreographer for the robots
months in advance they did the mocap for
this stuff and they actually got the
robots animated in so now they had an
actual animation file that they could
hit play on and watch the robots fight
so during the like combat sequences they
could use their live camera there on set
and see the robot in it exactly wow very
cool they had all these motion trackers
to figure out where the camera was in 3D
space and so once they have that they
can take the scene of the robots they
get twist it around and put it in the
ring and hit play and it plays at the
same time that the camera is rolling so
the cinematographer is able to get the
lighting set up for it to be like
dramatic the camera operator is actually
able to look at the robots and frame
them up but the footage they're getting
is still empty and so that gives the
effects artists the most leeway after
the fact that allowed the filmmakers to
make the most engaging action sequences
because they were able to see what they
were shooting as opposed to being like
well I hope we nailed it I guess we'll
find out in a few months when the
effects are started yeah it's like I'm
just I just pointed the camera at stuff
where I thought it would happen I hope
it works out if you're trying to film a
movie and you need to put a character
into a shot and you don't have virtual
production ready to go and you just have
to have to film the background make
sound effects imagine what you're seeing
and film it with your camera your
visible eventual VFX VFX character and
just make sound effects what's happening
it makes your timing and your framing
way better yeah it's actually a pretty
good Pro tip yeah but even doing that as
like a like a dry run it also would
really help
and another thing that I don't think we
talk about enough either is the idea of
post viz everyone knows what previz is
you like you know you choreograph all
the stuff beforehand but then you film
all these shots now the editor has to
edit this action sequence with just a
bunch of empty boxing Rings
it's like well what you gotta wait for
the effects to come in so the idea of
post viz is that when they film this
they actually have proxies of the Final
Shots that the editor can use and see
the editor is able to put on his CG
goggles or I guess CG uh reading glasses
rendering goggles because the rendering
because they're getting the actual
animations yeah it's not going to look
final or anything but it's enough for an
Editor to be informed enough on how to
edit a sequence but what I like about
this is how good the robots look they
look so realistic like the lighting
values are very very close between Hugh
Jackman and the robot even though the
robot is metal like it he fits in the
seam so perfectly there's that one
moment in time in our modern narrow
Cinema it's like when Transformers one
came out is when hard surfaced shiny
metal things suddenly we're able to look
real so before it didn't really look
real people hadn't quite figured out how
to do the compositing hadn't quite
figured out how to do surface shading
the rendering hadn't quite figured out
how to simulate the lighting and
Transformers 1 comes out and this kind
of comes out right after it where it's
like oh they figured it out finally I
mean I mean this was the Rock'em sock'em
Robots movie right like that was what
everyone laughed about and then the
movie came out and actually had a lot of
heart and I was like whoa look I'm in a
record store these records are actually
movies with visual effects and you're
the person working there and you're like
you've probably never heard of this band
but they're really good and then you
give me a movie suggestion I look at it
I'm like wow I've never heard of this or
seen it but boy the effects of this are
amazing I'm looking for more of that so
please leave some more comments down
below if you consider yourself to be a
movie hipster sign up now by leaving a
comment yeah